[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
Joe Madden the two-time World Series
champion manager three-time manager of
the year and now he's got a book out and
a podcast they're both called The Book
of Joe and the podcast with uh the great
writer Tom verducci available where
books are sold the book of Joe and good
to have you back Joe how you doing good
buddy good morning to you why aren't you
managing
um haven't been asked I mean that's
that's what happened the first time I
aged uh at that time Tommy Tantra
walking out of the ballpark and Boston
says how come you're not managing
somebody's got to ask you to do that
um I really don't know I don't even know
if this the the book and the things I'm
talking about in the book eventually at
the end of it may be discouraging some
from asking me which is fine uh and
that's cool but I I really felt a need
to talk about analytics in the way that
I have and if I get to work again
hopefully next year I'll take it and if
not I'll just become a better golfer
what role did analytics play in you
getting fired
uh it's not like it it did uh that's see
that's the point I'm really into this
stuff if I'm into the information I love
it I was pretty much at the Forefront of
it becoming popular in the game in the
uh like 2006 seven with Andrew Friedman
in Tampa Bay the problem I have is the
way um
it's being brought into the clubhouse
itself it's at the point where the word
I use is interfering I mean it gets way
too much uh uh credit for what happens
on a baseball field it really to me is
is most uh
beneficial when it comes to acquiring
players I don't deny the man defenses
and really the point where you're
changing and eradicating the shift a lot
of it has to do with analytics and
putting your guys in the right spots and
then a pitchers benefit hitters do not
but regardless of all that I just want
baseball to be put first again I want
coaches to be empowered again and I want
analysts to be put more in the
background
okay so this is maybe more for a selfish
standpoint of saying let's not forget
about the managers because it feels like
you don't need managers or their role is
diminished now
yeah I I agree and if that's the case
that's fine and I'm not arguing I guess
in favor of anything uh I'm just against
um the fact that as a manager your uh
abilities somewhat mitigated I mean when
you have voices in the back of your head
the moment you walk into Dugout from
everything that's been thrown at you
right before the game begins primarily
I'm talking strategically like bullpens
who's available who's not in a bullpen
situation I don't like that I don't
really like elongated meetings on a
daily basis I don't like presentations
uh players cannot hold on to
dissertations in a hot mama you're
watching these games and by the way the
games have been great I think the
playoffs have been outstanding and
hopefully it's going to attract more
fans and I think that's wonderful but uh
to think that all this information is
actually helping uh Justin Verlander
throw a pitch in a certain moment or a
fromber about it's not true it's just
not true I know maldonari does a great
job behind the plate but it's being
perpetrated that way and you're right I
think the uh the abilities of managers
are being usurped in a sense and right
the need to have them is really
gradually going away I agree with that
what would you do if you were managing
Jose Altuve who is in a terrible slump
over his last 23 but you're winning
what do you do to kick-start somebody
like that
um I I would definitely obviously have a
visit with him and typically typically
not just guys I mean he's uh he's not
very tall but he's got great power I
really would ask him to do two things
except your walks because probably I'm
watching I'm watching the games
expanding your strikes on a little bit
too up and get back into your Zone and
I'll just take singles up the middle
I'll take singles up the middle opposite
Gap you try to simplify things I think
right now it's getting quick regardless
of all the success you've had it can
still get quick in moments like this so
help him slow it down give them a more
simple game plan to approach uh try not
to analyze exactly what the pitcher's
doing do what you do better and again
that would come down to accepting your
walks organizing your strike zones and
I'll take singles up the middle
we there was a lot of chatter with Aaron
judge going for the uh you know single
season record for the Yankees and with
the pitches pitchers pitched to it if
you were managing
and let's say you were managing and you
guys were in a playoff run
so you got to win the game want to win
the game but what is your duty to the
game as a manager with your pitchers in
what Aaron judge is trying to accomplish
well I it's even if you're not in the
race you you're beholding to other teams
that may be in the race so you got to
treat it as though I'm saying if I'm for
instance this year Detroit and I'm out
of it I'm playing the Yankees I still
got to treat judges though I was
um the the Astros or another team that
was in the race towards the end of the
season you have to treat it with equal
respect so yeah I would walk them a lot
I think I mean it all depends on who's
sitting behind him
um I was even talking to some friends
saying it's going to come to the point
where he's going to get walked with the
bases loaded at some point I really
thought that would occur I know I've
done that I've been criticized with
everybody and it really doesn't matter
but I I think I thought that was going
to occur too so it all depends on who's
sitting behind him and what that kind of
protection looks like but regardless you
have to have respect for the game and
other competitors so that you treat it
as though this was kind of a baseball
life and death situation he's Joe Madden
he won a couple of World Series titles
and three-time manager of the year he
has a podcast and a book both titled the
book of Joe the podcast is with and the
book with the great baseball writer Tom
verducci was there any thought of
trading Mike Trout internally when you
were with the angels no uh was not um
that was not discussed with me at all uh
I love Michael should there should there
have been conversations
um you know you could make that argument
there's no question you could argue in
favor of that um just because you're
trying to replenish the system and who's
going to get more value back than a
Michael Trout's gonna get I mean you're
hearing the same things spoken about
shohei right now uh being in position
where you may have to make those
decisions not easy and um you know
things like that have happened before
it's not like it's ever occurred the fan
base would be up in arms obviously and
then you're going to have some kind of
uh uh you know things are going to be
written things are going to be said but
hopefully you make the right kind of
Trades you get the return of a year or
two from then it's going to be a moot
point but whenever it's going to happen
whenever it would happen of course it's
going to be an uproar but you have to
have uh foresight in situations and um
the fact that they haven't won in a long
time
we got up to a great start this year but
it just didn't want to work out of
course that has to be discussed
I'm going to make you show hey otani's
agent
I'll take it
right how are you guiding him uh where
do you want him to be after this next
year
um you know shohei is really his own man
I I known as the fellow that's works
with him and uh is is a translator ePay
we're really good friends
um he's I I think what's happened if you
remember when shohei first came over he
I think he definitely wanted to stay on
the west coast I think he was concerned
uh of course and also about having an
American League team where he could
utilize both right now the whole league
is open to him I don't think that uh
location or travel or as important I
think culturally
having probably been closer to Japan at
the point mattered but now I don't think
it matters as much I think he's really
gotten his uh uh you know his feet on
the ground in a sense when it comes to
the American culture so I think it's
wide open whereas in the past it was not
so it's going to come down to
um Choi wants to win man I listen one
thing about shohei
um he's great and he's got all these
things going on from but at the end of
the day this guy wants to win so I think
he's going to be motivated by that I
mean his money's going to come
regardless it doesn't matter what show
he goes he's going to make his dough
would you pay him two two salaries Joe
you have to I mean it's just two players
it really is I mean it's Unique to to
negotiate
uh or evaluate
Otani he's not one dude look at his
pitching record this year and look what
he did at the plate offensively now of
course everybody's going to say with
good health and that that that holds
true for everybody
um he's just his pitching keeps getting
better I've witnessed it personally
offensively it it's been really good the
last couple years you're paying one guy
to two to do two different things and he
does it on a level that's uh a top five
top ten in all of baseball if you said
or you had to decide he has to do one or
the other he can't do both
um that's that's that's Sophie's choice
right there that's a really difficult
thought I I don't know the answer to
that
um it's again I think he could be a
probably be an offensive player longer
it's just a matter of the arm holding up
stuff holding up uh things of that
nature uh but I'll tell you this guy is
is kind of a physical freak he's not
sore before after games I can't I don't
understand how he's able to play to the
level that he can after the days pitched
and thrown 100 pitches nobody can do
that nobody does that so I just wish the
man continued wonderful help and just
keep doing what he's doing for the next
five to ten years because it's really
special and I don't even know the next
guy that's going to come along to be
able to even kind of approach what he's
done and that's what I wonder you know
Sports is full of imitators everybody
wants to be Steph Curry uh everybody
wants to be Patrick Mahomes you're going
to have high school kids who might go
into it and and it'll be the shoheiotani
effect on the game where a lot of these
player players are really good you know
your picture plays shortstop when he's
not PL you know pitching when you're
growing up and I wonder if they're going
to be imitators who say look I'd like to
be a two-way player like Otani
it's possible more like you're just
you're insinuating there in high school
or college or you don't play every day
that's that's a different animal when
you're playing every day at 162 to be
able to pull off what he's done I'm not
saying it's not going to happen again
but I'm really curious as to when it
might uh yeah there's going to be
potential imitators and like I said when
you play three maybe three days a week
you could do you know absolutely we all
did it in high school but when you get
to the level that he's performing at
um I really don't think this can happen
in the very near future and if it were
to in some on some level not with the
kind of success he's experienced it's
great to talk to you you look good you
look yeah healthy gonna go play golf
yeah I'm gonna go play golf I got him
right on the golf course right behind me
here I'll be playing 18 with the buddies
in a couple minutes I'm a civilian I'm
having a blast golfing gardening and
Grilling it's a really difficult summer
to surpass
good to talk to you again Joe good luck
with the book and the podcast uh that's
true Madden and uh the book and the
podcast entitled The Book of Joe